Whitney Pennington Rodgers: There is
so much happening in the world right now.
Our guest today spends
her days and, in fact,
her entire illustrious career
tracking and reporting
on the moment's biggest stories.
She is CNN's chief international anchor
and host of the network's award-winning
flagship global affairs program,
Amanpour on CNN International in London
and Amanpour and Co. on PBS
in the United States.
I'm so thrilled to have her here with us
to offer context
on some of the news stories
that are impacting
our world and our lives.
And you can see her there right now,
please welcome Christiane Amanpour.
Hello, Christiane, how are you doing?
Christiane Amanpour: Whitney,
thank you so much for having me.
I'm so glad to be with you
for a few minutes and your TED community
on these really important issues.
And yes, I am the chief
international anchor, but before that,
I was, you know, the main
international correspondent.
So the way I work is always informed
by me being on the ground,
in the field and having essentially
walk the walk and talk the talk
with the people who are at the coalface.
WPR: I love that,
and I feel like that's going to give us
so much perspective
during this conversation.
Let’s just dive right in.
I think one place we'd like
to start with is in Iran.
For those of you who are on the call
who haven't been tracking,
back in September,
an Iranian woman, Mahsa Amini,
died in the custody
of Iranian morality police
after being arrested
for not wearing hijab.
Amini's death sparked protests
and a revolution
around women's rights in Iran and beyond
that is continuing into this very moment.
And, Christiane,
I know that you've reported
on Iran throughout your career
and have spent a lot of time covering
this story very closely.
So how historically significant would
you say this moment is in Iran?
And could you just give us
some context on that?
CA: Look, I think it is very significant.
Exactly how and what will develop
towards the end, I'm not sure.
A little bit of my own history:
I am half Iranian, and I grew up in Iran.
And I spent essentially
the first 20 years of my life in Iran,
with a little bit of going back and forth
to the UK for boarding school.
But that's where my home was
and that's where my parents lived,
and my sisters, essentially, you know,
I was there during the build up
to the Islamic Revolution of 1979.
And so I saw all that happening,
and that's what made me
want to be a journalist, in fact,
to tell those kinds of history-making
stories to the world.
And that's what really focused me
on the kind of career that I then pursued.
Fast forward now some 43-odd years,
and you can see that the women
who actually were pretty upset
at the beginning of the revolution,
when they had demonstrated for Khomeini,
believing that he would bring democracy
as he promised back then
to a country that was a monarchy.
And then to quickly find out
that actually that wasn't his plan
and to quickly find out that he was
putting women under the veil,
which he had not said earlier.
So for the first year
or so of the revolution,
women did not have to wear the veil.
And when they did, many, many women
came out and demonstrated against it.
And then for the decades since,
there's been a sort of a tug of war
between how strictly
to put on the veil and not.
And clearly differences
between conservative
and religious women
who want to wear the whole tight covering
that covers their head very tightly,
covers their body very loosely,
known as a chador in Iran.
And then those who just didn't,
the younger generation who felt, well,
they better, you know, follow the law,
but they were kind of
treading their own path
towards how they would wear the hijab.
And you could see coats and body coverings
were getting tighter and shorter,
head scarves were getting
more colorful and pushed further back.
Women and girls were going to great
lengths to make themselves look beautiful
and stand out as women.
They would do their hair,
particularly the front of their hair,
which stuck out of the scarf.
They would, you know,
bangs were not forbidden, you know,
beautifully made up their eyes,
you know, their skin,
their lips were all just beautifully done.
And Iranian women are incredibly beautiful
women in spirit and in body.
And that seemed to be kind of OK.
But what happened towards the last
sort of, ten years or so,
you've had a slightly
less draconian regime
when it comes to enforcing hijab.
You know, in the late '90s, early 2000s,
and then a much more draconian,
which is the latest one.
So these very hard liners, this mullah,
you know, Ebrahim Raisi,
who is the very hardline
conservative president,
actually came to the presidency
by using as his political platform,
among other things,
a much tougher interpretation
of what they believe, you know,
the Islamic laws should be.
And, of course, who paid
the ultimate price? Women.
Because it's always, whether it's in Iran,
whether it's in Afghanistan,
whether it's in the UAE
or in Saudi Arabia,
or whether it’s in parts of Africa,
whether it’s in the United States, etc.,
women's bodies, women's personal space
seem to be used, you know,
for people's political aims.
And so the same happened in Iran.
And this poor, poor woman,
Mahsa Amini, at the age of 22,
came with her family from the Kurdish
region of Iran to visit relatives
and was wearing a scarf
and was wearing a body covering.
But the police on the corner at that time
didn't think it was conservative enough.
And that's why there's a backlash.
WPR: Well, you know, in recent days,
a story was circulating that some
15,000 protesters were to be executed,
and the veracity of the story
has been challenged and disproven.
As I understand it,
it's actually more like 15,000
protesters have been detained
and the parliament voted in support
of the death penalty for protesters.
But it's not ultimately up to them.
So I'm curious how real you think
the possibility is that something like
a mass execution might actually
happen in the near future?
How real a threat is that?
CA: Well, you're right that this story
was chased down, including by us,
and it turned out not to be
as it was being broadcast.
On the other hand,
there are many, many,
I mean, you know, hundreds,
if not thousands of people who've been
rounded up and put into prison,
whether they are women, men,
young girls, other young people.
I recall hearing one of the top government
officials saying several weeks ago
that the average age of those
who are being arrested,
this is an actual
government official there,
the average age was 15 and 16.
And I mean, just think
about it for a moment.
I mean, that's just unheard of anywhere,
that children, young girls,
people so young are in the front lines
of this protest, this uprising,
this movement,
and are being punished.
And then the latest stories,
particularly by my colleague Farnaz
Fassihi of The New York Times,
who’s an incredibly good reporter,
has brought out,
I mean, some of the most terrible stories
of how young people are being dealt with
in a very harsh way.
And, you know, there was,
over the weekend,
there was the burial of a young boy,
10 or nine years old,
who was, you know,
a victim of all of this.
And he was killed.
And his funeral happened.
There was another big protest there.
And, you know, these things
defy normal behavior.
And even for, you know, an Islamic
republic that's been pretty draconian
for the last 43 years.
And this goes way beyond, you know,
riot control or whatever
you might want to call it.
So the question again is, because I know
those outside of Iran want to know,
is this the beginning of the end,
or is this the end of the beginning,
or is this the end
of the Islamic republic?
And I'm just not ready
to say one way or another,
because you just don't know
to what lengths they will
finally go to crush it.
And so I'm waiting,
as a journalist should,
I'm watching, I'm waiting,
I'm interviewing,
I'm getting as much information
as I possibly can.
And I'm going to be doing it
on my show today,
which will air, as you said,
on CNNi and on PBS.
And I've done it many times
with many Iranian interlocutors.
And ...
This is a very brutal regime
when it comes to staying in power.
But the only thing
that I think is interesting,
well, there are many things
that are interesting,
but what's somewhat different to before
is that within the Islamic establishment,
you have voices, actually male voices,
who are questioning why they need
to react this hard against girls
just for the hijab and the headscarf.
So we'll wait to see where
that conversation gets to, if at all.
WPR: And as someone with such a close
personal connection to Iran,
that part of your heritage and then also
just your close reporting of this story,
what do you feel are the things
that most of the world is missing
or not seeing about what's
happening there?
CA: Well, look, I think in general,
foreign policy and stories
from around the world
are hard to get past the American public
because they're hard
to get past our own editors.
So if there was more reporting
on a more regular basis
of these kinds of stories,
we would have a much better --
and you all would have a much better idea
of trends, of what's actually happening.
You know, don't forget,
Iran is a very important country
to the United States
and to the rest of the world,
partly because of the sort of upheaval
that the Islamic Republic
and including backing terrorism etc.,
have caused to the world -- and holding
hostages as they continue to do.
Iranian Americans, British Iranians,
and a whole load of others
who are in jail, used as political pawns.
And this is, you know, a very,
very unfortunate and tragic situation
where human beings are being used
as political weapons.
So they're weaponizing people
who just happen to be half Iranian
or they've left and they have become
you know, they've taken on the nationality
of the countries
that have given them refuge.
And when they go back to visit family
or on personal visits,
they have been dragged
into this political turmoil.
So that's really bad.
And many governments
are having to deal with that.
The other issue of why it's important
is because of the Iran nuclear deal.
Now, I think that's
off the table for the moment.
It was always going to be off the table
pending the midterms,
but now pending,
you know, this crushing of this movement,
the US has imposed more sanctions,
Europe has imposed more sanctions
on individuals who are deemed responsible
for the harshest crackdown.
So it's very important.
Iran remains a very, very important
country to the world.
And don't forget, you know,
it has a huge population,
and such a huge majority of the Iranian
population are under the age of 30
or, you know, they're
in that young generation,
which means they're
incredibly well-educated,
they are well-connected to the world.
Even now, even though the regime is trying
to cut them off from the West
and cut the world off from them.
They manage, you know, to play
a very sophisticated technical game
of cat and mouse
to get their stories out and to get
information from the world in.
So you can never cut
the Iranian people off.
And they would benefit
and I hope they are benefiting
from the support that they know,
the moral support
that the world is giving them.
On the other hand,
I know there are others who call
for more support to overthrow the regime.
That’s not my space
because I’m a reporter,
and I report on what's going on there.
And I personally don't
believe that anybody,
any foreign government
is going to do that.
And I also believe that the women and men,
the male allies inside Iran ...
This is their movement.
They don't want it to be sullied
by any interference from abroad
that could get them even more tarnished
than the regime
is trying to do at the moment.
WPR: Christiane, we're getting
a lot of questions from our members,
and I'm going start to bring some
into our conversation.
We have one from TED member, Don,
which speaks to what you're suggesting
around this idea of global support.
They want to know
how can we help from afar.
"I feel helpless, but would like
to do what I can
without putting more women
in harm's way," is what Don shares.
CA: Well, it's very hard.
I mean, definitely moral support,
definitely spreading the word,
spreading the word
and supporting the Iranian women
in whatever way you can.
Some people ask, how can we send
them material support,
whether it's money
or whatever it might be.
But that's very, very difficult,
and I do not have an answer for that.
It's difficult because Iran
is so heavily sanctioned.
So it's quite often illegal, actually,
you know, by American law
or European law or others,
to actually send money via various ways,
as far as I know.
Maybe there are ways that it’s possible,
but I don't know those ways.
But it is quite difficult
to provide, at the moment,
more than material support.
I would say, I do believe
the world should be a lot more generous
to those who are trying to flee this
and any other kind of repressive regime.
Right now I'm in London,
and as you know, over the last
several, certainly months,
there’s been a crisis
in the English Channel.
And a huge number of Iranians are trying
to get away from the danger zones
and into the UK.
A huge number of Afghans
and potentially others
fleeing wars and devastation.
But they get turned back.
And I think the world's asylum
and refugee policies
have become so draconian
and have gone so far from being
what they were envisaged as,
to welcome those who are fleeing
you know, terrible oppression
and, of course, often
starvation and disease
you know, and natural
disasters and the like.
And I think that's a real shame
that we're seeing in this time
of maximum upheaval in these
parts of the world,
the rest of the world
actually closing their doors.
And I'm about to do some interviews
around a new film that's coming out
called "The Swimmers."
And just to say, it's about two
Syrian girls who had to leave Syria
at the height of the Arab Spring
and during the Iran-supported crackdown
by the Syrian regime
on those who were demanding freedom.
Anyway, they managed to get out,
but they had to take
a rickety boat to get to Europe,
they had to walk for miles,
then they had to wait for months,
you know, for asylum.
You know, people like you and me
were dying in the Mediterranean.
They're dying in the English Channel.
They're dying, you know,
coming across from Africa.
This is 2022.
It's a scandal.
And I do believe that that lack of asylum,
that lack of refuge is a terrible shame
and a blot on all of us
who believe in human rights
and democracy and the value of life.
WPR: Well, I want to move
to another part of the world,
also experiencing a huge crisis,
where you've been spending a lot of time,
both reporting and actually
physically being there.
You just returned from Ukraine.
And we're now more than nine months
into the war there.
So could you tell us
a little bit about your trip
and what you saw as the people
there are heading into the winter.
What would you like for us
to know about what you saw?
CA: Because you just said winter,
I think it's really important to know
that what Putin is doing now,
because he's been thwarted
on the battlefield,
is he is literally taking
this war to civilians
in a much more targeted
and devastating way
than he has been already,
which has already been
attacking civilians.
But this relentless attack
by cruise missiles
and other really, really powerful --
including Iranian-supplied
kamikaze drones --
this is attacking civilian
energy infrastructure on a regular basis,
it's sometimes attacking civilian
residential buildings
and ordinary people
are being killed and wounded.
At the same time,
what turned out to be a phenomenally
resourceful Ukrainian population,
whether civilians or experts,
let's just take now the engineers
in the energy sector
are working around the clock,
day and night
to try to put this, you know, back.
And they’ve done managed,
rolling blackouts and the like
to try to make sure that they can save
some of the energy infrastructure.
And particularly,
let's not forget how tightly intertwined
is electricity and water.
Those two are yin and yang.
You can't really have water
without electricity to pump it.
And so if you lack water,
fresh water just to drink,
you're in real big trouble.
And so the Ukrainian engineers
are working around the clock
to try to make sure
that people have at least,
at least, even if it's rationed, access.
So that's a big issue.
I would say I've been completely
and utterly overwhelmed and surprised --
not surprised, delighted by the spirit
of the Ukrainian people.
You know, I've covered a lot of wars
in which much more powerful,
heavily-armed aggressors
try to subjugate and force
a less heavily-armed
civilian population into surrender.
And the Ukrainians are nowhere near that.
They have so much heart,
they have so much love for their country.
They have so much respect,
as the Iranians do,
for the idea of independence,
sovereignty and personal freedom
and political freedom and democracy.
That's what they're fighting for.
And frankly, they are
our frontline troops.
The Ukrainian people right now,
and to an extent, the Iranian people,
are our frontline troops.
In Ukraine,
people are standing between freedom
and totalitarianism.
And if Putin succeeds
in Ukraine, then he's ...
I mean, not only do the brave
Ukrainian people lose,
but then he comes
a country closer to the West
and continues to threaten
the ideas and the values and principles
of democracy and freedom.
And this idea that it was NATO's fault
and NATO expansion,
I promise you that is fake news.
It's too difficult right now to go into it
because we only have limited time.
But it's not that.
It's that Putin does not want to see
a free and independent
and democratic country,
in this case Ukraine, on his borders,
and then be asked why he can't have that,
why his people can't have that.
He doesn't want that.
He wants to create
his own sort of greater Russia.
I witnessed that covering Bosnia,
where the Serbs, backed by Russia,
wanted to create a greater Serbia
on the backs of the Bosnian people.
And in Iran, too.
And you've seen the Afghan women
and girls now saying,
"If Iranians can stand up
and demand their rights,
it's our turn next."
So these have huge roll-on effects
and inspiration to people
who believe in basic freedom,
dignity and the right to live their lives.
WPR: Well, I know while you were there,
you sat down with Ukrainian
President Volodymyr Zelensky
and first lady Olena Zelenska.
And I'm just curious
what your thoughts were
about their mindset
at this point in the war
and how you think
that will impact their leadership?
CA: Well, I think their leadership
has been extraordinary.
I mean, really, who would have thought it.
This man Volodymyr Zelensky came
from the entertainment space.
He ran based on a program
that he had been starring in,
a TV series based on corruption
at the highest level.
And so he ran as a clean candidate.
And then when he came into office,
that's what he tried to bring in,
to increase infrastructure
and to improve it
and crack down on corruption,
because Ukraine did have,
and may still, after the war,
have a corruption problem.
But believe me, now,
that is right on the back burner.
And US senators
of both parties have told me
that everything
that the Americans are sending
and NATO is sending
is accounted for,
and they are not worried about it
going into somebody’s pocket.
Unlike in Russia,
where it’s gone into,
obviously, people’s pockets
because they have barely
a military machine
that can operate in Ukraine,
much less against NATO.
Their leadership has been inspirational.
The fact that the president did not leave
when he could have done,
he did not take his wife and children out
when he could have done.
And the fact that they keep
"poking the bear,"
and I asked him that.
I said, "You know, a lot of people
in the West are worried
and elsewhere are worried
that if you push Putin too much,
you "put him in a corner"
and he might do the unthinkable."
And he said, "You know what?
We've lived in this neighborhood forever.
If we're not scared,
you shouldn't be scared."
And I was saying this
because not only are they
pushing him militarily back,
but also if you look at the Ukrainian
Defense ministry
or any of the online space,
they're constantly trolling Putin.
Constantly.
And it’s done with incredible humor,
and it’s very, very effective.
And so they know something
that we don't know.
And as Olena Zelensky told me,
"This is our last stand.
This is it.
If we don't stand up now,
there is no other time
when we can stand up.
If we don't do it now,
when are we ever going
to be able to do it?"
So they're very, very clear about that.
As you know, there's been some
talk around the world,
some talk in the US and Europe, elsewhere
that maybe, you know,
particularly after the liberation
of Kherson by the Ukrainians,
shouldn't the Ukrainians sit down
at the negotiating table?
So I asked President Zelensky that,
and he said, "Look,
we're happy to negotiate,
but based on international principles,
based on the Russians
removing their troops
from their illegally invaded,
annexed and claimed territory.
You know, and sham referendums
and sham annexation.
And by the way, we're pushing them back."
So they don't want to be pushed
to a negotiation
while they have the upper hand
and one that would reward
Russia for its aggression.
And to be honest with you,
we don't want that either.
We do not want Russia
to get away with today
what they did get away with
in their first invasion of 2014,
when the world did not stand up
and did not challenge him.
And this is the result.
He thought the world was weak.
And that's his big surprise.
He was very surprised
that the Ukrainians would stand up,
the West and NATO would stand up,
and that this unity
would last this long.
And, you know, I come to it
from, you know,
having covered something similar
in Bosnia for four years.
I mean, this was an ethnic cleansing,
which they're trying to do in Ukraine,
the Russians, along the east,
and it was a genocide,
which I believe that ...
maybe not genocide,
but crimes against humanity
will be placed legitimately
at the feet of Russia after this war.
WPR: Well in both Iran and Russia,
and thinking about Ukraine,
we see a suppression of free speech
and access to information.
How can we know that we're receiving
accurate updates
on what's happening
in both of these places?
CA: Well, I do think you and everybody
have to take on a certain
sense of responsibility
because that is the challenge of our time.
You know, people ask me:
Where do we find the truth?
And I'm like, well, you can watch CNN,
you can watch PBS, you can watch BBC.
You can read The Wall Street Journal
or The New York Times
The LA Times or any number,
Financial Times, whatever.
There are many, many organizations
who are committed to the truth
and who have reporters on the ground,
including in Russia.
The BBC, for instance, has a very, very
accomplished and good reporter
called Steve Rosenberg.
I highly recommend you all
to access his reports,
because under the constraints
that Russia has put on journalists,
he is managing to tell the story
in a very, very clever way.
And also, I would, you know,
just look at the Russian
state media, Russian blogs
and this and that,
including the military bloggers
who are traveling
with Russian troops in Ukraine.
There's a huge amount
of information coming out
that actually paints the accurate picture.
And right now, they're very --
which is not to say
they want the war to end,
but they're actually painting the story
that the Russians
are doing badly in Ukraine.
So there are places and avenues to go.
But I believe that it's really
up to the consumer now.
We can do as much as we can
to bring you the truth,
fact-checked, evidence-based
news information.
But you must not go to the fake news sites
and believe that that's the truth.
You must go to what I would call
the news organizations that have earned
the Good Housekeeping seal
of authenticity and truth
and, you know, approval.
It's really on you all now
to search for those.
And it's not hard, they exist.
WPR: As we get close
to the end of our time,
I just want to turn things
to you, Christiane,
and your thinking
as a reporter, a journalist.
How would you say reporting
on conflict and crisis
has changed the way
you think about the world,
your perspective on life?
CA: I think it's changed my perspective
in that I'm very clear
that I can't be a both-siderism,
or “on the one hand/on the otherism.”
In other words, in certain instances,
such as gross violations
of international humanitarian law,
which we're witnessing,
in other words, you know,
human rights atrocities,
crimes against humanity,
genocide and the like,
you absolutely have to know
where the truth is
and what you're looking at
so that you know that there are aggressors
and there are victims.
There's no two ways about that.
So my mantra is and has been,
and I've developed that from Bosnia,
which was one of my earliest
experiences in the field,
my mantra is "truthful, not neutral,"
which doesn't mean to say
I'm not being objective.
I am being objective
because objective is our golden rule.
And by that I mean you have to look
at all sides of the story
and report all sides of the story.
But what you mustn't do
is create any false equivalence,
either factually or morally.
And when you do do that,
you are actually being untruthful
and in some cases you're being
an accessory to terrible atrocities.
And I would say the same about climate.
I mean, you can talk
about any of these crises,
these moral and existential
crises that we find.
You know, climate has been too long,
for decades been treated
as a both-siderism,
that the deniers had equal factual
or moral weight as the science.
And it’s just, as we know, not true,
and so much time has been wasted
to the point that we are on the brink
of a global catastrophe.
And that is something that I've learned.
That in order to be a trustworthy,
credible journalist,
I must, must call out the truth.
WPR: Well, I want to end
with a question from a member,
which is basically,
"If you were to interview yourself,
what would be the last question
you would ask?"
So here's your last question,
what is your last question for Christiane?
CA: Oh, Lordy.
My last question, I don't know,
but I do know one thing.
That I wish that I would be able to --
I guess it would be, how can you get
more access to the other side, you know?
I want to say the bad actors,
because they are.
How do you get more access to them?
You know, I would like to sit down
with a Putin or a Kim Jong-un or whoever,
Viktor Orban in Hungary
or whoever is denying democracy
in the United States and the like.
I would like to sit and talk to them
to try to understand.
Not because I think
that I would be, you know,
I would suddenly become
a neutral observer,
but because I want them to spell it out
so the people can see
and I would question them rigorously,
that they would see the bankruptcy
of their positions.
And I would like to keep doing that
with fossil fuel executives and the like.
I've done a few and with governments,
you know, who have allowed
politics, politics to endanger us all.
I do believe those people need
to be held accountable.
So I would like to be able to ask
those people more questions.
WPR: Well, Christiane, thank you so much
for taking the time to chat with us today,
I think I speak for everyone,
just appreciating
everything that you’ve shared.
and good luck with the rest of your day.
CA: Thank you very much, I appreciate it.
It was good to talk to you all,
thanks Whitney.
[Want to support TED?]
[Become a TED Member!]
[Learn more at ted.com/membership]